THWAY OF ALET IN
THEORY, THE OLD  GOES. HSAA ORTR
PRESIDENANIAN PH
ALL SORTS OFS EXPLODE
ILD ACCUSATIONS ABOUY CLIN
DEATH PENALTY.
HOSOFSOURCES" JOINS MT WING OU.
FILIT TO FROM OFANL
THERE TO HERE, WHAT HAPPENED
>> THERE'S ALWAYS A LITTLE GERM
OFITTA
INVESTIGG SSIA PROBE.A
CNN HEADLINE ABOUEL DURHAM
ALLEGE LAWYEUSED DATA TO RAISEU.
A LITTLE BIT OF A STORY,
OF ARYBUT IT WAS BLOWN
WINGEDIA AS IFRUMP
ON,  WASRIME O
DONALD TRUMP HIMSELF SAID IN A
STATEMENT, AT NGER TIME IN
OUR HIST DEATH PENALTY
APPLIED TO THE
IMIS
PROVEN RIG THOUGH THAT
IS NOT TRUE AT ALL.
THIST  DAY
IN RIGHT WINMEA
TED TO FIZZLE.
>> IT ST
JOHN DURHAM RE
STATEMENTOS UP
S?RIGHT.
THE AIR STARTED TOZLT OF
A BALLOON THAT SHOULDN'T HAVE P
INTEETN HERE THE OBAMERA, NOT T.
E FIVE AND SIX
HYPED,Y
COVERARONG
THAT IS ALWAHE ISSUE IN
THESE STORIES, JOHN.
THERE'S ANPTHIS
TRY TO SAY TRIS
HE'S WRO DE REAL
NEWS THAT YOU COVERER ABOUTH CRE
AND SINS OTHP ERA,OR
SSIFIED CUTHEY JUSWA
HILLARY CLINTON
ALL THE HEADLINES HAN
ABOUY CLINTOY
SPNGS LLEN AN.
THEY'RE BASIY TA
ABOUT HILLAR.
SHE DID SAY INH THISLL COMTO
E'NG YOU'RCO
LIBELLING M